what is the Strategic campaign messaging
to reach Millennials in Tennessee
well I look I said I have one little
phrase that I think became the most
powerful phrase in the history of
politics and maybe
in any country you know what the phrase
is make America great again
that's going to be his messaging to
Young People by the way it's the same
messaging that got him almost no youth
vote in 2016 and almost no youth vote in
2020. that's his message
go into details and you know what the
details because we've been talking about
them the whole night
make America great again another one
America first we put America first right
they're putting them that's really going
to resonate with Gen Z you can just tell